[Music]
on the right
they do it right cause we coming at you
locked back with the team had to keep it
all G must see TV yes we did cause we
back at it again
[Music]
thank you
back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
yo we're ready to start Chad we're ready
to start I I had a um I think real quick
daddy cut his own hair recently because
there's one long string like your Alpha
yeah well Daddy does cut his own hair I
know now here's the personal spot when
when when here's the problem there is
something about getting older where you
I used to be a bit of a cutie pie yeah
sure I had my nice hair for your hair
yeah but I don't think about that
anymore I it's a it's a it was a um an
arrow in my quiver that I could always
lead with and I took the arrow out it's
not there anymore there are women that
still like me like I'll get some weird
some girls into it Daddy it's not like
it was it's it's not at all like it was
but it's also I just stopped thinking
about it it's [ __ ] weird because I'm
a little embarrassed that you're not
cutie pie anymore well no I would be
embarrassed to flirt now where I used to
only oh I'm embarrassed because I don't
want to be creepy yeah yeah I hear you
does that make sense yeah so you want to
be a creepy old guy I did a show last
night in these a couple young women came
up and they were very complimentary and
stuff well I should tell you I I micro
dosed a little acid
I mean hey yeah I'm into psychedelics
okay now hold please okay because I want
you to know something a drop
a drop like a tiny drop in water you put
it in water this is how you microdose
LSD I've never done LST yeah I'm not a
seasoned Tripper as you know well who's
doing this for you a guy okay it's a
seasoned guy you know some when people
go through midlife crisis they've been
like a Corvette or whatever yeah Daddy's
going and he does Daddy's opening some
portals sure let's see what's there
whatever you want to tell you so let's
see what's there right you start surfing
so what you start surfing no I'm gonna
I'm gonna get to that weird stuff I'll
get to that I'll get to that in a second
because
I do
um I do [ __ ]
quarter of a drop so it's a drop think
of a drop yeah it's according CBD it's
just like a little dropper like you
don't drop yes I did a quarter how do I
know that what color is it I assume it's
the one you put it in a tiny bottle of
distilled water you shake it up I drank
a quarter of that now an hour and a half
later I'm
I'm not able to really talk to anybody
but I am I've been writing a lot and I'm
writing like a [ __ ] wait hold on
this is you decide to do this before you
go on stage well this was in the this
was after my podcast Conspiracy social
club and I had a lot of time to kill
because I was writing and I said let me
see what Steve Jobs is talking about let
me see what happens when you do a little
uh yeah yeah he was you do a little
micro dose so I I get into that without
going into what happens where I go for a
walk where there's a Sizzle in your
brain there's a Sizzle you are
definitely in an in a beautiful altered
kind of you're just very focused you're
not thinking about food you're not
thinking about your phone
I go and have I'm finally able to drive
because you know after about seven hours
whatever but I I drive I have a great
half-life's like two hours or something
no longer than that okay see how long
LSD lasts well eight to 12 hours 8 to 12
hours we can confirm this but that's my
guess okay it's literally longer than
any other compound well there you go now
that's a that's a quarter drop drop
hey bro hey bro hey bro you're the
[ __ ] guy who was like Game of Thrones
I don't I'm not talking to you right
about 12 hours I don't if you gave me 12
oatmeal cookies for 12 hours be quiet 12
hours let me get through my story yeah
please do okay yeah please do don't be
oopsie right now I'm just saying you're
being a little 12 hours though hey all
right keep going keep going okay
be a little bit be a little bit into
this no I mean I'm into I'm just saying
B all I'm saying is for me I wouldn't uh
my only reaction to that is when he says
12 hours we don't know yet look it up
chin [ __ ] no no Mark knows I I've been
pretty confident that I did look it up
and said can last up to 12 hours and
that's been my experience if you do a
quarter hit it's not gonna last that
long
here's what I'll say is that it if you
do a smaller dose yeah you'll feel a
smaller effects well I will I will admit
this much yeah after about seven hours I
had to be driven to where I was going I
wasn't going to take the chance to drive
I I was fine to drive I just don't want
to take the chance because I was a
little bit out of it I was a little bit
too focused on what would be in front of
me and I'd sit on what's in front of me
I don't want to get into a car and
actually be driving I don't think it's
responsible yeah I was fine to drive but
you know now I get to I have an amazing
meal alone at Via Veneto and it's an
amazing meal because I'm just in my own
head I'm totally cognizant but I'm in my
own head now I got to get up and do
stand-up at this awesome room called The
Rose Room this new room in Venice and
it's right near the beach and I'm like
I'm literally sitting there and I'm
going I don't know
I literally don't know how I'm gonna do
stand up right now like I don't know how
I'm going to focus on anything and I'm
not thinking about stand-up I've been
thinking about my set all day because
I'm writing new [ __ ] but can you talk
like you can talk
I can talk and I can listen but I don't
want to be what I can't deal with is
this if somebody starts talking small
talk I feel like they're in my face too
much you can hear it yeah so
everything's a little more sensitive
anyway I get up it was the best 45
minutes I've had in probably five years
and it was all improv I improbbed and
added [ __ ] in and it was some of the
best stuff I've done I believe it in
[ __ ] two years I mean bro because you
don't have any restraints right you
don't get no [ __ ] exactly none it was
like when Rogan I smoked weed and drank
whiskey a long time ago when I was doing
Rogan's podcast when he used to at the
ice house and he goes get up I go I
can't one of the best sets I've ever had
I'm not again I I'm not saying you
should do a lot of psychedelics I'm
saying if you're an adult like me at 55
it's not going to change my life I'm not
going to discover new [ __ ] but it might
open it might open some portals where
I'm not in my own way as much where I'm
where I'm playing and I just got up and
played it depends what you want out of
it I just played well what I want to do
is I don't know I want to shake up when
you get a certain age and you're
creative sometimes you get caught on the
same questions yeah sometimes you got
you get caught in the same uh you know
the same mode of thinking you ever find
yourself on the same train sometimes
your brain feels like it's on tracks and
you're thinking about the same [ __ ]
there's a certain routine to your life
that you want to get rid of you need to
shake it up you gotta shake it up well
where do you go after that is that
what's the acid today I'm joining the
Navy Seals
like like you graduated to Aston you
started with shrooms there lasting
what's next
uh I feel like two weeks when I ain't
coming like dude last night I did math
okay and no don't be crazy I'm not
saying do math all I'm saying is I
didn't eat for seven days I'm shredded
okay yeah there's the best out of my
life the energy insane yeah I didn't
sleep for seven days yeah well somebody
who's done cocaine and Adderall those
are terrible drugs they're fake
psychedelics used responsibly and
occasionally I think are are and by the
way acid LSD is the is has almost zero I
don't think it has any toxicity it
literally remarkably Mark and I were
talking about this there was that urban
legend when I was a kid that that person
did uh acid and then thought they were
an orange and peeled their skin that
never happened so many urban legends
dude again heard that I'm out yeah yeah
right I'm not gonna peel my skin I
didn't do it till my late 20s because I
heard so many negative things yep every
time of that Carl Hardin does uh heroin
doesn't work out I'm sorry I I here's
what I have to say no one ever did
cocaine meth Adderall heroin and the
next day went was a good idea but people
have done psychedelics instead I'm glad
I did that more times than not probably
and I would say that because it's not a
pathway towards addiction right right
because I believe you can I think his
point because I've read about this guy
before was like I casually use heroin
and only it sounds interesting though
doesn't it I'm I'm not a nicotine I kind
of like this guy right I know some
people like you'd take nicotine you're
like I want more of this there are
certain compounds that I go I could take
it or leave it and other things I really
like
he's basically saying look the chemical
hooks idea if you do heroin once and
you're going to be addicted forever it's
not true and you you in theory could do
it like once a month I don't know many
people who do but you know it's an
interesting perspective and you're what
you're saying about LSD is like is true
it makes you
sillier and more playful and you don't
go I need to do that again right now no
not at all yeah yeah there's like a
taboo on heroin again I don't know
maybe that doesn't I don't know it
killed rock and roll yeah heroin killed
rock and roll psychedelics and weed were
when it had his Heyday in 68 and then
they got into heroin and cocaine dude
[ __ ] kill mess that's your teacher
when he comes out I was like listen guys
it's a new heroin I want to be very open
it's like what the [ __ ]
series for many years The Logical and
findings on drugs such as heroin I read
this yeah I just he says regularly for
five years in a row so far according to
this articles it's crazy if he's if you
know to say it's not a addictive drug or
that you can't like there's a way you
can do it and not be addicted that's
insane
straight years of regular hair yeah dude
he works at an Ivy League school well
that's that's what that's the state of
Ivy League education I I would imagine
that some people have a chemistry that
deals with drugs differently Rogan
obviously gets better on weed and I get
I'm a complete idiot on weed it's just
chemically there's a difference that's
it so yeah I mean I feel like maybe this
guy's an outlier like he goes I do not
have a drug problem never have each day
I meet my parental personal and
professional responsibilities pay my
taxes serve as a volunteer my community
on a regular basis contribute to Global
communities informed engaged isn't I'm
better for my drug use cool if it works
for who gives a [ __ ] though yeah sure
like I don't care I literally do not
care I mean most of the time we're
thinking about people who take pills
every day because you get addicted to
opiates but it's like I got an accident
then you're taking it every day how much
do we study like oh on Saturday I smoke
everyone you know I think it's kind of
an unknown
that he's just he's an outline he's an
outlier I mean the problem is when you
start glorifying heroin yeah and he's a
smart dude and has his [ __ ] together
then kids like well I can do heroin yeah
maybe it's not for you dude correct you
know like weed's not for me I'm with you
I just my body doesn't react well though
never has
I think the one thing the one thing um I
was talking to my buddy who grew up in
Somalia and in the Middle East like it's
very very common for men in men
especially at night when it's not as hot
to come into a room everybody sits on
the floor and in places like Somalia
yeah in places like Somalia you would
chew what's called chot
or got it's it's a it's actually a leaf
it's very acidic but it's a sedative and
sometimes it can be a stimulant
depending I've chewed it and nothing
happened to me when I was a kid but
people sit around and they chew it it's
probably a little bit like creative I
think but you chew it it's very [ __ ]
common and very very
um
it's very uh it's done a lot and they
just sit on the floor and they [ __ ]
talk and they'll do it every single
[ __ ] night and if you're 12 13 14
you're invited in with the men to sit
and talk it's a fun time it is it's just
it's a loss it's something we've lost
it's something we've lost we the
community and getting together at the
end of the day at churches yeah yeah but
that's that's usually on Sunday they'll
do this too oh oh yeah really Wednesday
math oh yeah damn who does that well
[ __ ] I'm popping yeah oh yeah that's
good good for churches have you done
that yeah yeah yeah did you grow up
going to church yeah really my dad yeah
and that's why I know that must have
been boring for you well my dad let's
make a choice when we're like six like
you want to keep doing something six no
we got out because my dad was like it
was awful so my dad grew up super Cafe
last time you went to church no no when
I first came down I went to church all
the time really Wednesday Sunday
yeah me and Tebow Wednesday Sundays
popping popping young good looking oh
everyone's sexy so you know that they're
dressed up you know this is a new thing
right this is uh I talked to a guy who
was a who worked for the Republican
party in DC I don't know what he did and
I said did you see the Roe v Wade
overturn he goes I saw it [ __ ] two
years ago so what do you mean he goes
you don't you don't you haven't seen the
religious the Christian Revival among
young people in places like New York
City I go what and he brought up like he
brought up the churches in New York City
alone among young urban professionals
and how many people have found Jesus
it's astonishing the stats would beg to
differ because there's more atheists
than ever in the world amongst in
America depending on where you go
atheism is like like less so in America
way more in Europe
more here I'm like the Millennials eight
atheisms huge no not so there's a
religious revival among Millennials
watch this maybe it's pop and especially
in the South religion that's religion
football that's always been the case now
it's in the [ __ ] North he was showing
me this stuff
it's crazy man
wow 22 atheists make up 3.1 percent whoa
that's it
well 22 no atheists the they're not
they're not affiliated with the religion
like atheists are actually only three
four one percent a lot less unaffiliated
22 that's like you know how many people
that is well that just means they don't
go to church
yeah they don't I mean yeah but but Chen
look up seven percent of the world New
York City uh [ __ ] what is it um
resurgence
yeah like like a Church Catholic
Resurgence Church young young
churchgoers there it is
let's do that first No Deal
Revival look at this these are all
different stats because you're going in
New York right yeah it doesn't have to
be a larger Trend to be a place
yeah this is weird
Okay yeah it's when it started now it's
like you know
look at this [ __ ]
it's super old yeah I know
yeah but you need Community right it's
one of these pillars I just think that
it's interesting Church attends declines
well also met a lot of older people go
to church so I'm sure with code but
they're not Gathering I just think all
of us get so busy and none of us
actually we don't have those Villages
you don't have that sort of community
that we do anymore you find Jesus dude
maybe that's how this ends all this drug
[ __ ] you see Jesus well in a way it's a
search for God as far as I'm concerned
for these people yeah sure it is you
think you're a fine guy I think that's
what rude awakening like you say there's
not many like breakthroughs if you got
found God if I was like then I would
take it then I would take you well the
guy who started one of the co-founders
of AAA saw a guy when he did an LSA D
trip and he founded A.A yeah and you
could make the argument a a saved off
continues to save a shitload of lives it
doesn't work for everybody it's got a
big fail rate but it saved a lot of
lives and and uh that's their bit it's
like baseball that's the game of
strikeouts he he found but he found Gods
he saw God and [ __ ] fat co-founded eh
can we take a little break please take a
break dude listen if you're looking for
a breaking link for a great time in
Wisconsin Appleton next Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm in Appleton Wisconsin now
laugh meter hits red hot and apple oh
the laugh meter you better make sure
that thing is oiled up September eight
nine and ten let's face it there's not a
lot to do in Appleton let's be honest
your boy's in town or an OshKosh or any
of the areas around you might want to
come see their boys now the show tonight
in the prep sold out but Appleton
Wisconsin almost sold out September 8th
through the 10th then Ontario California
Ontario Improv is September 15th 17th
then I end September Austin laughed
Boston September 29th to October 1st did
you take that thickboy.com there you go
and oh yeah tomorrow we launch uh the
new YouTube channel it's just uh Brennan
Schaub Comedy All YouTube you get weekly
clips uh stand up Clips funniest moments
from podcasting it's a whole new YouTube
channel that's Brendan Schaub on YouTube
well you know I'm gonna be speaking of
YouTube channels Tim Kennedy and I it's
a probably gonna be a 45 minute episode
I'm best of with Brian Kellen and I'm
dropping that tomorrow Tim Kennedy takes
me through what it's like to do Special
Forces he's so much fun we had such a
blast they're on tour too right B oh
yeah we might not launching a special
but I'm launching a special sometime in
early September that's what's going on
Raleigh North Carolina good nights
September 8th 9th 10th San Jose
California Improv September 15 16 17
Spokane Washington Spokane Comedy Club
September 22-24. and then I'm in Tacoma
the following weekend my September easy
I know September 29 to October 1. come
get some and then by the way Bridgeport
Connecticut Stress Factory October 13
through the 15th ah there it is the wait
is almost over Kid the new football
season is about to begin get ready for
the NFL week one action with draftking
Sportsbook all right NFL week one action
with draftking Sportsbook that's right
the NFL is here the official sports
betting part of the NFL to celebrate the
return of the football DraftKings is
giving new customers I can't miss offer
bet just five dollars on any football
game you get 200 in free bets instantly
want more action for opening night say
less everyone can experience the thrill
of DraftKings early win promotion get up
seven points you win listen you bet on
team they don't have to win the game as
long as they get up by seven points at
any point during the game you'll win you
get paid instantly even if they lose
DraftKings safe secure reliable best of
all you can deposit withdraw your cash
whenever you want download DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use promo code
fighter better you get two hundred
dollar rules and free bets instantly
when you place a five dollar bet on any
football game that's code fighter only
at draftking Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner the NFL minimum
age eligibility Administration Supply C
show notes for details see you next page
for directions for disclaimer that's
draftking Sportsbook app download use
promo code fighter can I ask you do you
experience while on LSD an enhanced
perception of the interconnectedness of
things yes yes no I just because that's
almost like the funnels yeah it's like
yes is I look at trees animals and
humans and go like I'm a part of this
and it's a sensation I can think about I
know it it's true when I'm not on LSD
but when I'm on LSD I'm like holy [ __ ]
we're all one thing I I what I did is I
started connecting dots I don't connect
normally and I started being able to
define the difference between things
that I've been thinking about in uh in a
better way yeah and I Did It On Stage
last night and it really hit see do you
wish I found it before do you wish you
did this stuff before like years ago you
think do you know what I wish I'd done
before Bubba is I wish um I wish that I
had been more like Rogan in that I
wasn't as naive
to the consequences of not living
brutally honestly like and more
importantly I wish this is really what I
wish I was I was I came to LA and I was
told Brian just think about acting and
stand up and all the business stuff will
be taken care of by other people never
think about business because it'll get
in the way of your art and that was the
dumbest [ __ ] ever they think of it I
wish somebody said Brian you are your
agent your manager you you are running
your own business you're the CEO of your
own business work on your brand learn
branding learn business and stop saying
it's not for you yeah because it's and
and what really really what I wrestle
with every day is having to relearn or
at least or at least redefine that idea
in my brain so I wish I wish I had been
I wish I'd been way more paranoid of
people yeah and I know you feel that way
too I mean I've always been yeah you've
always feel that I've always been like
you've been way better I've been way
better as far as the market my own
business to not rely on managers and
ages no and also people people too I
think I'm too I was always too trusting
yeah and everyone always told me
including you but especially like my
clothes my all the people that really
know me including family members were
like you bring you bring in way too much
of the broken and crazy yeah you waste
your time on it I wasted my time but uh
but now yeah you and I are Polar
Opposites when it comes to that stuff
like obviously business side of things
that's what I like to do stuff like that
and you had a meeting last night with my
management and agents I'm tired man
because I do everything myself I'm tired
so I told him I said you know I'm I'm
it's not that I'm
relinquishing power but I could use some
help I told them that I could use some
help letting other people help you it's
a trust thing it's it's also a really
probably a very important thing for
business if you look at people that
really have big you can only get so far
in your you can only get so far yeah
that's what I said last night I said I'm
I've learned the hard way I'm tired man
like I can't is there any way other than
that to learn is there have you ever
learned anywhere anyway other than the
hard way because me neither I'm tired
man me neither
tired so hopefully they can help out and
if not all good so there's someone who
can you know maybe it's not them but
hopefully it is but that's why I told
him last night I said I'm finally ready
to admit and give you guys your
percentage I'm tired I need help man
wouldn't you say all this network all
this stuff to stand up it's a lot man
wouldn't you say that I would say this
like finding really people that are
really good at their jobs even if it's
menial or even if it's a smaller job is
like gold it's like finding [ __ ] gold
people that give a [ __ ] about themselves
that's fine you know like work ethic and
not just ride the wave what that's why
Chin's so good try finding another chin
go ahead good luck chin or Mark yeah
both of them are Mark yeah I didn't call
Market two in the morning yep I got done
with that meeting yesterday Mark's the
first person I called so what do you
think that's what they think I should do
like I think you could use some help
dude and that's what I told him last
night I said between the whiskey the
network stand up the merch
uh all these other branding deals it's
like I'm tired man I'm sick of dealing
with myself there has to be someone you
can handle this one all right I said I'm
[ __ ] tired there we've been telling
this for years I know but I to be fair I
don't think I would have gone as far as
I did if I had depended on you guys I
said I'm ready to give up whatever it is
part of maybe doing it on your own you
had to do it on your own so you could
see what you can't do on your own yeah
part of it sometimes you have to try
everything see you see what what you
what you can't do yeah it's a huge asset
to have that chip on your shouldn't be
like I got this on some whatever I can
do this but then it's also it's you're
only gonna fly so high yeah you know you
need help that's right and all the big
dogs have there's a reason why Kevin
Hart has help and [ __ ] you look at all
the big dogs that's the reasons
he's kept all the same people with him
yeah Kevin came up with all those guys
they're Comics also I don't want to do
it alone now [ __ ] lonely it's lonely
it's [ __ ] lonely and a boar and
there's something about building
something with a group that's just so
fun so I have all the guys here I don't
need half of them yeah it's like a team
yeah they're gonna hate him but I just
like a team wait a second
they'll grow into the business as the
business expense hopefully you know but
I like having a team walk in and like
everyone's you know doing you just gotta
hope everyone carries the work well Tom
Cruise was working on a movie with our
boy and uh the guy yeah and I said well
it's taken a year and he still said no
and he said yeah because when he says
yes to a movie
about
a thousand people eat I was gonna say
the next time
no it's a thousand that was a job
everybody has a job I mean it's more
than that because he's such an industry
that if he says yes to a movie first of
all it's got a hit yes and so if it
doesn't it he feels responsible for
everyone putting their kids through
school everybody's like this am I on the
Tom Cruise are we working for a year two
years and you know he doesn't miss no he
doesn't miss If he if he signs off on
Project you know he's gonna put all his
all into it he spent like a year with
our friend almost like almost every day
and then then was like called it no how
about that Savage [ __ ] Savage I just
feel guilty saying no and probably go
through without him and then it flops
ain't that crazy in my career you know
isn't that crazy I know Savage Savage
Savage that [ __ ] that that's
Excellence I love when people criticize
I think I like that I know do you know
what it takes to be him do you know what
it takes to be a guy like that
well how about the biggest movies ever
done the newest one the new Stop Gun
this movie he's ever done biggest
Blockbuster hit ever he stick is he 60
yeah he's got to be right dude when that
movie starts and he's the opening goes
hope you guys enjoy the movie I want you
know these are real g-forces these are
real Jets we rented you're like
he's 60. look at him
it's just unreal
Brad Pitt's 58 yeah holy [ __ ] yeah
Brad Pitt's 58 yeah Tom Cruise was doing
the goddamn thing my Pitt's still doing
a damn thing oh my God he looks
phenomenal he's going through a hard
time with Angelina though they're suing
each other over the the wine she's
chewing them over abuse
you know that she left by FBI reports
yeah yeah it's tough yeah but in front
of the kids it's very very suspect that
she brings this up now
he did well he grabbed her about this
this is the FBI report so grab you know
that's what she reported remember she
likes oldest [ __ ] though yeah but
remember she this is what she said
notice the FBI report oh she's saying to
the FBI yes oh yeah because FBI's not on
the plane no uh no so she said basically
he got upset hit the plane wall grabbed
her in front of the kids yeah that's
when she got out yeah he grabbed her by
the shoulders and said you're [ __ ] up
this family that's what he said
so it's like okay oh and then he poured
beer on a blanket she was under hmm okay
and they have to write all this stuff
down without any contacts at all
it had sustained 25 000 worth of damage
from spilled red wine I mean you know
that's her word who knows
so she was [ __ ] on this fan now
listen
and then he said you're not taking my
[ __ ] kids I don't buy any she's I I
she listen she's actually she's crazy
yeah so see I'm sure there's some talk
way less he's just
way less
she's the one who sold from under him
that [ __ ] wine company that I Rush an
oligarch it was a hostile decision and
also a breach of contract and they
worked their ass off but she won they
did he took her to court and she won did
she yeah I don't know what's going on
with that did she I don't know yeah she
she won that whole dilemma which is
weird I I mean they settle out of court
she won no he he or she took him to
court
see one's battle over French
whoa
took control of the Chateau that sits on
the vine Vineyard and the pit has been
toying with a breathtaking buildings
ground ever since but Jolly sold her
stake to liquor giant Stoli setting
emotion a web of lawsuits
Pitts Camp has flat tooth and nail to
have a court denied Joey's request for
the papers and correspondence keep going
but on Friday a judge in La said that
Pitt and his Partners must Fork them
over to opposing lawyers and said that
they can't even hold off until they
appealed the decision sounds like a
[ __ ] a judge that was a big Angelina
Jolie any rational human being would be
happy for Stoli to be a partner they
have top-notch marking distribution
um they have a few drop chains to grow
the business he just can't see past his
hatred for Angelina Jolie look at that
place it does look magical and they got
married there gray wine it's a [ __ ]
great it's a good one oh great it's the
best Rose I've ever had I think wow but
the source code spit tell us that not
only a story deal not a no-brainer pit
head turned down and offered to sell it
to stillie while he and Jolie were still
married they said that the idea of
selling a chunk of the business for a
better distribution has counted his
long-held plan for the project which is
to plow profits back into the company
plus they said the best way to retain
value for the kids for the parents to
retain full ownership agree of the
increasingly valuable and expanding
asset who the [ __ ] knows what happened
six children I mean they're both
outstanding talents and also Brad just
buy another Winery you know
okay I think that he wanted a legacy and
he won he wanted his kids yeah you get
it and she sold it to Stoli yeah a big
boy like you saw at the corporation yeah
your kid's kind of [ __ ] yeah and
anytime you do that yeah
the quality goes down the value might go
up because the district no they'll blend
it now what they're going to do is take
their minds you know you don't know the
contract contracts you don't touch it
just give this distribution that could
be part of her contract right I don't
know yeah don't diminish the brand don't
you know
the distribution now calls everything
it's literally everything it is
everything what's that mean this
distribution like I think tiger thick
we're in like 24 States like around all
50. you don't where I'm at you don't be
in all 50 because you don't have the
manufacturing the product to be in all
50. but where they're at I'm sure it's a
big boy for them to be worldwide
distribution being all the restaurants
all the chains Costco wherever they're
at that's where you're making money in
some cases case cases that's you know
distribution
wow
that's cool yeah it sounds like that's
what she's trying to do expand the brand
yeah distributions literally everything
amazing let's get her bad
that's how Colin blew up his
distribution was insane oh really insane
and and that's why this brand is worth a
billion dollars or something and then
people are like all right we'll take it
that's so [ __ ] cool yeah it's all
distribution I love it I love it I love
it I love it
um what are you laughing at mark
I'm just thinking about Conor McGregor
really why
um I just got a kick out of him and also
some of the things so I didn't know that
you'd met him before oh yeah did the
podcast yeah yeah no oh yeah and like
hung out yeah I was the analyst for
Showtime that I was the Conor McGregor
expert yeah
um is he uh I think about his recent
video of him like doing like this she
had video him getting sucked off by his
wife on a yacht no yeah really yeah you
have no idea no this is going around
yeah I mean it's everywhere a lot of
funny memes about it yeah he uh weird
Flags yeah it's your wife dude
but also I again I always use the glass
half full I look down guy the guy's
living getting his dick sucked he's like
yeah yeah 500 million dollar yacht he's
on Mykonos Island like it's just a good
visual when he comes back he fights yeah
spell fellatio
when he comes back I wonder who he wants
to fight
I hope Jake Paul's gonna be fighting
Anderson Silva that's the Rumblings yeah
yeah that's true that's a tough fight
for Jake oh yeah
but I told Jake that when he came to the
uh that's not it gin
um sex acts video sure I don't know yeah
uh that's the pig so that
that's the picture I mean it's a little
if you go to any MMA site it's literally
the biggest news we don't have to see it
yeah you can't really even see it it's
just
it is a weird Flex it's your wife dude
it's my wife all right yeah cool anyways
yeah I mean just living yeah I don't you
it's his wife who gives a [ __ ] it's all
good man yeah look at that beard
yeah Jake Paul uh interesting so it's
not hasn't been made official but I
think Ashton Silva's team leaked it and
I told Jake that when he was at the
Improv I said you know at the time he's
going for bizbing so dude Bisping has
one eye he's an analyst he's moved on
you're not going to get any respect if
you knock out Bisbee he's a legend but
the dude has literally one eye do you
know that you think really I'm like I
don't mean like blurred vision I mean
it's one high fake eyes and by the way
Victor Belfor Vitor yeah so it's like
you're not going to get uh respect from
that financial and Silva I'm gonna say
it's my idea I push them into it I'm
there it is still nice
there it is and he put that on his
Instagram I'm like oh there's some guy
getting head on a yacht and then later
find out it was Conor McGregor now some
people
look at that view though like I looked
down I was like this guy's crushing life
that's great it depends where you're at
in life how you view this you're like
this guy sucks I went wow that guy's
really killing it I'd be grease yeah
that was nice yeah I was there dude a
[ __ ] blue Beach of a dick suck I mean
you guys living dude he's probably a
Gucci robe right one of those moments
you're not when you're there you're not
going I wish I was somebody here
somewhere else you're not saying I wish
I was on a beach no no he's won hey hey
he's won everybody there it is get back
pointing there and get back down there
that's hilarious kid's gonna grow up and
see this yeah yeah the whole thing is
just weird dad's a wild one
dad's a wild horse Wild Horse Wild one
he's a wild one
the the larger question is the uh
transition will be interesting for Conor
McGregor but I think yeah transition to
get fighting yeah I just
losing the juice and and now what's he
do he'll be a business guy it's tough
when you're worth 600 million dollars to
fight these monsters and you know you've
been out of the cage for a while like
it's a tough gig man that's not what
this Sport's about like it's gonna be
tough it's surprising hearing whenever I
hear the behind the scenes of Fighters
you know that are big names and you're
like oh yeah that guy party animal like
or this guy does I was like yeah it's
crazy to me it makes sense but I never
thought about some of these huge names
like oh yeah they love to party because
I'm like isn't it like you got to be in
Peak physical condition going against
these dagestanis that's the problem drop
of alcohol that's probably barely
trained for
uh it could be yeah I couldn't imagine
it I couldn't imagine yeah
but I could do some coke and drink every
night
there's that one thing that the like
Islam in a way a lot of people would
argue got right where it's like Muhammad
said alcohol no no good things come from
alcohol basically yeah a lot of he's
never had a good whiskey but yeah yeah
well a lot of them are very good birds
don't have it but look at how many
families are destroyed how many [ __ ]
jobs are lost because of alcohol that's
a weird point to make like look how many
families are fine no it's like football
too we'll we'll go to drugs how many
people are addicts how many people do
heroin and mushrooms and acids what do
you think the country would be like if
you said
um like if you had a no alcohol no drugs
policy like Saudi Arabia someone would
be America I don't know I wouldn't want
to live here we get fatter well would it
be a positive
I don't know
how many people drink or fine the
majority
um the alcohol causes massive damage so
there's drugs well that's what I'm
saying you want to cut out all drugs all
alcohol there there is a school of
thought and it's and it belongs in in
one a lot of Islamic countries have
found great
success in that the problem is when you
have that kind of the ability to
suppress that does it then stop
creativity
you know what I mean in other words I
just think Freedom's got to cut across
the board right yeah it's like if you do
that then all right we want to be the
Middle East well that's that's what I'm
saying how are they doing good with the
back how are they doing
the Middle East
you know I get what you're saying like
drunk driving and stuff like that but
then also it's kind of like football and
CT and kitchen play it's like you know
how many people play football and are
just fine the majority but What story do
you hear CT CT cool you know the amount
of young kids that play football that
are just [ __ ] fine the majority and
also what do they get from football like
they discipline all that like the
heartache like this life lessons yeah
you might have headaches and stuff but
man you get a lot out of sports like
that you take away alcohol like this
some guy's working nine to five right
now who are chomping at the bit for that
5 p.m well like anything else if it's
used responsibly a good bottle of wine
with friends is pretty good yeah
yeah well it's like censorship
like you know when you start censoring
people like that I was watching Andrew
Tate on Tucker Carlson I don't know yeah
but they [ __ ] like they took
everything they took everything dude
including his Banking and stuff
I think it's wrong too just because you
don't agree with one of his political
States well they didn't agree with his
his covert thing he said this is I'm
trying to overreact but Blossom agree
but remember too Tate is very pro-trump
and very loud about it so the left
anyone who's pro-trumper Pro Republican
they're gonna they're gonna come for you
man and the clintons have been doing it
for years like you look at I mean you
kill them they literally took his entire
livelihood they took his his b this is
his domain my point is this is nothing
new what should scare everybody's tape
Andrew Tate is very famous very wealthy
you know what I'm saying
very popular among young men they took
all of that all because they didn't
agree with his stance that's right
very alarming right it's very alarming
to me I'm not a fan I I don't I didn't
follow him but this is I just think it's
but this is nothing new like if you go
back
YouTube's gonna suppress this because
all the drug talk even though we talked
about in positive light and we're not
going to be in the addicts or anything
like that don't suppress this because
they don't agree with it now they might
suppress us from my views on whatever it
is politics then you know it's their
platform and they believe in you know
the far left politics and that's who
runs gotten too powerful to behave that
way though agree you can't say you're a
private company so we can run how we
want no no you're globally used man yeah
I mean you've gotten so big like Twitter
and all this stuff I I just think that
when you have censorship who's doing the
censoring and on by on what [ __ ]
grounds yeah it sounds like your
ideology and your political point of
view doesn't mesh with a guy like Andrew
Tate well we'll look at look at our boy
Rogan yeah our boy Rogan was within
Rogers and you had Mark Zuckerberg on
for that either Rogan's getting too big
so when Rogan goes Terry and Rogers goes
you know I tell everybody if you don't
like what happened with lockdowns with
all the cove and stuff like that vote
Republican all right so you're gonna be
a pro Republican read the news right now
it's all anti-rogan it's all ban broken
from Spotify just because he said hey if
you didn't like the way the left dealt
with coveted protocols vote the other
way yeah now he's the enemy they're
gonna do everything in their power to
censor him to shut them down this is has
been going on politics for years anybody
that doesn't play the part you're gonna
get silenced you're gonna use your
livelihood Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton who pretends she's Pro women's
Choice Pro women's right has been
silencing victims of Bill Clinton for
years this is what they do man they make
you out to be this Black Sheep No I mean
this is what happens man
this is this is exactly what happens and
they get too powerful and I do think
that big Tech sounds incredibly biased
although there are a lot of right-wing
people making a fortune on social media
so you know but I I I don't know here's
the thing they're making a lot of money
they could be making even more money if
it wasn't ran like there should be no
politics in social media there should be
no Banning there should be no silencing
if you're gonna have a board have a
board from left and the right or have
people that don't have interest in
anything be the dictators of what's
misinformation what's not because we've
known for how long now that they silence
the Biden uh the the Biden laptop laptop
they silence people that said things
about covid because they thought it was
misinformation now we know it's not so
it's like obviously the people making
decisions are morons that we can't trust
you guys still leave them and pay them a
salary they can't be trusted there's
clearly an agenda here well you you this
is where the higher education is
[ __ ] dangerous man like in in how how
they've been completely hijacked by one
side of the debate but anyway yeah man
that's scary I don't know but I I was
looking at this and and entertain said
when they when it comes it comes hard
like I watched everything evaporate I
mean within minutes his his ability boom
boom they're gonna silence you
ability to [ __ ] use banking like you
know imagine someone took away your
banking be [ __ ] well uh Tim Paul said
it's going to create a parallel economy
it's going to create uh you know other
people are going to create their own
banks for people like that you know but
yeah people are too powerful and I think
there have to be I don't think so I
think what's going to happen is because
it's powerful there on the left they're
just powerful on the right they're smart
more there's more business on the right
than left oh yeah so those people on the
right those smart [ __ ] and go
all right that happened to him how do we
prevent this how do we create Avenues
where if they do do that you're still
able to make a living they're going to
come up with something unfortunately
it's that Andrew Tate's expense but
they're gonna come with some and these
dummies trying to Rally to ban Rogan
they got 7 000 retweets
very cool maybe let's say it's at a
million which it's not but let's say
it's in a million let's say it grew
1.3 million overnight which it didn't
because it's not happening right let's
say that you realize just still just a
fraction of broken support yeah that's
right I mean come on Mora yeah
yeah and he's not Republican no all he's
saying is we saw how the left dealt with
a crisis but if they would obviously
they didn't handle it well but they
don't listen to it and he goes so if you
don't agree with that there's only one
other way to vote which would be this
which just happens to be Republican he's
not saying he's Republican or far right
he's just saying if you didn't like the
way that the left dealt with lockdowns
and took over and ruined small
businesses vote the other way it's
pretty simple
it's kind of like saying if you don't
like Roe versus Wade vote you know
correct vote Democrats Republicans which
is what's great about our democracy you
have recourse every two years every four
years
if you don't like it you can actually
take you can organize and you can you
can take your efforts to The Ballot Box
awesome yeah you know what I find
annoying and it's I'm watching this Bill
Clinton Monica Lewinsky trial and all
that stuff
what's so annoying is like I said bill
was a Democrat so when Bill Gets in
office the sole job of the Republicans
which it should be America first is to
bring bill down instead of making
America better yeah same with Trump the
sole purpose of the left was to bring
Trump down it still is whoever whoever's
in office with whether it's Barack Obama
then the Obama the the right wants to
bring him down yes but that's that's not
moving the football for the country no
all you're doing is you you're there's a
district school of thought that said so
the founding fathers and James Madison
John Jay Alexander Hamilton they talked
about this
they wanted to make sure that government
was fighting with each other so they
wanted to make sure the way you prevent
teams the way you prevent factionalism
was so one faction gets powerful the
biggest challenge for James Madison is
how do I how do I stop one group of
faction
from getting so powerful and acquiring
all the other factions and everybody's
so afraid and then we're stuck with it
guys running everything that makes sense
so that's why he had they they came up
with this this system of checks and
balances and a bicameral legislator so
you have the Democrats Republicans that
are always fighting against each other
what does that do it cogs the machine up
it makes government work nothing it's
done nothing gets done things go move
very slow as the president you can't get
anything the founding fathers that was
by Design they said you want this and
it's stupid though yeah no but they want
you want it to go slowly because what
happens is and that's the other reason
why they said it's democracy but it's
refined democracy so you have the house
and that's all the your direct
Representatives you can write
representatives there so they go let's
pass this law because George Floyd had
his next step down whatever it is you
know let's Pat and it's very hot
everybody the the local populace wants
to [ __ ] tear down they want to
snatches yeah and the idea was yes
that's pass a law it's on the house
floor
it's going to get voted now it's got to
go to what the wise men yes and the wise
men who are there every six years
there's not as much pressure the wise
men then who are older Senators then go
guys come to us let's chill emotional
yeah there's a little much there's no
problem is it takes for everything it
does and then the president if there's
more than two-thirds he can veto it yeah
he can say no I'm not letting this
happen
then the Supreme Court it can be
challenged the Supreme Court can say
this is actually not constitutional now
their job is not to pass laws but to
interpret whether this law is
constitutional or not that's Roe versus
way they said actually constitutional
right to choose should be a state by
state issue because it's not in the
Constitution yes and there's strict
constitutionalists the problem with that
is that they start going down the tally
there and they all right gay marriage
all that's not in the Constitution
that's the issue which is why
technically in New York now you can
carry a gun yep because it's your
constitutional right if you don't have a
criminal liability or whatever you can
carry a god
it's a it's an interesting time it is
but the Republicans overreached because
there are a lot of women and men who are
like I don't want to live in a state
where if you get raped or there's incest
you know and you get it I'm sorry to say
it but you have a 12 year old who gets
raped by Uncle Tony she's gotta have
that kid and breastfeed before or after
Girl Scouts yeah somebody's got to make
those decisions
I've been talking to the guy on his
podcast about it no I'm wrong hold on
you tell me if my daughter gets raped by
guy the guy goes there's a lot of
children that come out of rape and
they're actually good people everyone's
like I don't give a [ __ ] dude yeah yeah
it's nice
that theory is you don't commit a murder
you you don't you don't kill you don't
commit murder because you don't make a
rape better by committing murder meaning
this is their their lie which I disagree
with yes which is they've commit to
murders by the way but yes but like so
so in other words you're you're saying
that abortion's murder okay that's your
that's your that's your belief fine but
you're saying that if uh uh middle
schoolers raped she should have that kid
that's insane you want are you gonna you
want to be involved in that and like you
told me that kids are gonna grow up
normal get the [ __ ] well how about if
it's an uncle yeah how about if it's
incest
and and what what was that what God
wants was God in the room yeah was God
in the room when she was being okay yeah
or was he taking a nap dicey man well
the problem is that these are problems
that we have to deal with you know I
think the right [ __ ] up with that and
then the left there's constantly [ __ ]
sure yeah yeah they both [ __ ] up well
both Trump runs the Republican party
like a [ __ ] mob boss like you gotta
kiss the ring oh yeah do you want to run
as Republican you better like you they
were talking about this in this book the
guy goes well what am I supposed to go
grovel because he had said something bad
about Trump to the [ __ ] to Fox yeah
dude and and his assist his uh his
campaign manager goes
literally goes exactly well yeah yeah so
he had to go the one thing about Trump
is if you go and kiss his ass in his
room he's like ah you know
not good not good all right what do you
got Jen
all right uh real quick on that Andrew
Tate thing did you hear what he said
about the whole sex trafficking thing
yes he was swatted well he was swatted
yeah you know
when people just call someone
yeah yeah and it wasn't true they said
they said he's keeping women against
their women
cops got there it's like some haters his
brother there the maid was there I think
his mom was there and they were found
nothing yeah
became Witnesses and they're running
with this narrative so the cop said
you're all witnesses to the fact that
nothing happened they got he got swapped
yeah that ain't right but then but but
the media keeps it on oh it's all I
heard that's when I heard sex
trafficking I was like all right well
now they're dealing with some real
that's what happens and the other thing
too I mean she came out and said like we
were role-playing you know like he's
been dating her that's his girlfriend
but it's amazing how when you take that
and even oh no that was when he had
there was a video on Big Brother yeah
where he was hitting her with a belt she
came out and said that's our thing yeah
she asked for it I guess that's her
thing yeah which is it's their intense
for me but if that's what she likes I
mean you gotta give everyone she said
that right it was consensual it was a
role-playing activity consensual
Behavior
yeah in conjunction you know it's like
oh and all this pops that's been there
before but they're acting like yeah
she's talking about misinformation hey
mainstream media you first yeah you
first
all right what do you got to all right
it happened again you're intense today
there's another sex act at a baseball
game oh
I mean the other one's just sucking some
weiner this one they're full he's he is
balls deep in this woman so she's on top
yeah
that's uh interesting and then here's
another security comes up yeah
all the way up there it's like
an hour's pants down
I wish they kept playing where security
is like hey excuse me hey guys
no [ __ ] kind of see them here
yeah oh there's a rock pile area it's
like you're at the back of the stadium I
didn't think you'd get caught those
cameras everywhere no he's up there is
pretty lonely the wind I think some
people's lives are so [ __ ] boring
that they go let's get caught [ __ ]
literally I get it right like sometimes
you gotta shake it out I get it but also
just
you know go to your car
so this Southwest Airlines pilot they're
fine to Cabo San Lucas and then I guess
some people on the Earth sending nudes
they were sending the pilot a bunch of
nudes on the plane oh for mayor yeah
airdrop dude this is how old I'm getting
I don't know how to use airdrops so
someone's like let me airdrop to you
buddy
let me see you know we're gonna have to
get some security involved
medication that's gonna be ruined
whatever that airdrop thing is let's
take a picture let's get yourself to the
gobble
it depends if there's a group of girls
and they're just wild you know they
might be doing that also be cool man
yeah just so you guys know there's so
it's a Southwest flight they were going
to Cabo and people were air dropping
pictures to the pilot also hey bro I'll
see life isn't booming I'm on Southwest
be cool be cool it's already bad enough
I barely get a [ __ ] seat take a look
at it yeah we all get on this plane like
[ __ ] cows but you know he's probably
super uh religious no just [ __ ]
paranoid worried he's got to say
something
otherwise he's being a voyeur and then
he loses his job for not saying we can
just cancel when this ship pops up you
just can't just yeah also just just have
fun with it hey guess the Cobble [ __ ]
how about that I I've had air drop I've
never had naked pictures but do you have
it a lot allowing everyone yeah if you
allow everyone apparently it's a big
thing on in New York and my one buddy
told me that's how I met girls they sent
me a picture like it'd be they'd be at a
bar and they'd take a picture of him and
his friend and they just ear drop all
the girls in the bar and they're like
hey did you and like oh my God I'm so
sorry and they start the conversation
but then also to the other Dark Side of
that guys on the train in Manhattan are
just sending dick pics on the trade yeah
you know it's like if you don't if you
have it on you get some dick which I
would laugh I listen maybe I'm a
different kind of breed here I would
laugh my ass if dudes are sending hey
fellas what are we doing who has the big
dick in here whose big dick is this
there's the guy was who was uh he was a
furrier and and he's making expensive
first for all the celebrities and these
this this woman who's like this she's
really hot and she's like an actress and
she's a Peta activist and he starts
getting into a whole thing with her you
know they start you know fighting and
and and he's like yeah but these animals
are farmed and all that [ __ ] you and
finally he just sends her a massive dick
pic
like here you go all right oh oh you
don't want me oh you want me killing
skunks
oh those poor it doesn't make sense
though oh the I may put all those poor
gerbils so aggressive it's so aggressive
although I've done that to you and was
she like uh you've done to me I've sent
him a picture of my balls my house
Hope New Mexico's fun dude New Mexico or
you're in Montana with your family I'm
like oh the vacation's going great
I'm like dude my mother-in-law I know I
know I can't help it
my ex-wife I sent her a picture of my
just impossible dong she was with her
friends and it was back remember when
your pictures would just show up yeah
you can do anything [ __ ] dude and he was
like your girl sent me a video of you
just washing your anus in [ __ ] Bora
yeah she was looking at your friend oh
yeah that's right
I said hello
I'm cleaning myself that's right do you
not know Brian that's what he does you
don't even you didn't even miss a beat
no what do you want me to do let's find
out what do you want me to do look at
your friend boom yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's him that'd be Brian
we've never seen him wash his ass before
in his restaurant sink you guys already
kind of talked about this this is what I
have to say about Jake Paul Jake Paul
versus Andrew Sylvan is rumored for
October he has some balls because this
is listen Anderson Silva beat Julio
Chavez Jr who's 50 and three happy time
world champion I love him and like beat
his ass you know what I'm saying like it
was did work this is a tough fight for
Jake man he's a boxer
47-25 I'm I that's balls to the wall
right dude he beats him I know the the
community Box means like still not a
boxer [ __ ] dude Anderson was set to
fight Roy Jones Jr to in his prime
that's how good he was at boxing until
Dana put the kibosh on it Jake Paul is
serious man yeah man I respect that
that's an exciting fight I agree
do if you beat him
it's gonna be pandemonium this guy's
very serious about being a box right 25
47. his age his youth on his side
what else you got you all right tell me
what you guys think about this this is
uh
so one thing about this that we're going
to get to later she's cekia she's a
czechia which is different than
chechnyan I just figured that out today
she is but uh so she's 16 years old
she's been from Czechoslovakia so the
check
is from the Czech Republic chechnya is
from Russia yes yes big difference yeah
yeah one's Eastern Europe and the other
he knew that I don't think we knew that
it's kind of it
I'd say I'm a child yeah Republic yeah
um
Yuri's from Czech Republic and then uh
hamzat's room correct yeah okay so this
is her dad her dad
does the coach tab around this yes let's
check it out okay let me see
I didn't think much of it until I
watched the video and it was little a
little odd
know which one's the dad which one's the
coach yeah
the first one's the dad
she just won yep that's the dad that's a
dad
it's nothing okay that left hand's weird
I know that's also dad who gives a [ __ ]
it's just so many Taps too but that's
the dad of course all right let me see
the coach coach could be weird
okay okay what I mean that might just be
there they're not even thinking about
that [ __ ] I mean they're all up on that
booty yeah there's a lot of viewers out
there it is a handful of that oh it's
that kind of a team yeah oh it's one of
those teams they're tight-knit groups
and the first one was kind of halfway
and you're like oh that's it and then it
goes down further and just does eight of
them it's a dad though so I don't have a
problem the coach okay I did a little
rubbing okay Coach is like oh oh it's
prison rules we're allowed to do that
yeah yeah the coach went oats Prince
rules cool I'm gonna grab ass too it's
like Jimmy Burke when when I was dating
uh my girlfriend and my girlfriend
blowout ass yeah this is my serious
girlfriend for I don't know at the time
seven years and we're we're sitting
there and she's got got sand like on one
on her ass cheek her thigh and her and
her calves and she's she's just standing
there and Jimmy just I'm standing over
him and he just leans down and he goes
he goes he goes you got some sand on
there right because you got some salmon
here and over here like that and then he
just goes
he starts doing this he just looks at me
and he just keeps saying what the [ __ ]
are you doing
but Jimmy's it's so funny
we start wrestling in the [ __ ] stand
I just attacked him he's so funny he
goes the [ __ ] are you gonna do
yeah and then one time then one time I
call her and he happened to be there
because he was gonna meet us and I I
didn't I'd forgotten and he and for
whatever reason he said he goes hello I
go hello and he goes yeah what's up I go
is Patty is Patty there and he goes
she's in the shower what do you want I
go who the [ __ ] is this he goes where
the [ __ ] is this I go this is her
boyfriend [ __ ] you know me I was
young yeah you mug I couldn't wait and
he goes yeah not anymore [ __ ] he's
using like a voice yeah yeah
[ __ ] dude that's funny it's so funny
where is he right now would he ever come
here Jimmy yeah [ __ ] yes yeah that'd be
so cool to have him on he's producing a
place he's so funny the best
all right check this out so the baby
who's like one of the biggest stars in
rap obviously
he got canceled yeah Elton John so he
can play Coachella and [ __ ] like that he
did the the his thing age remark or
whatever I just find it too basically
yeah you're saying like if you suck dick
then if you don't suck dick if you're a
guy and you don't suck dick then put
your you know cell phones in there if
you if you don't have HIV or Aids it's
basically saying if you're gay yeah yeah
he did at like the height of cancel
culture so this is pretty crazy so this
New Orleans place it holds up to 14 000
people he couldn't sell
uh he couldn't even get sell of 500
tickets is that because they're saying
it's because of his anti-w whatever but
then they also said there's the EDM act
on and for whatever reason the people
don't want to go see the EDM yeah that
sounds a little bit more like uh but
then he there's more to the story than
this I don't trust the story no I will
say this like uh in the hip-hop game and
they're saying it's there's like
three or four acts in the world that can
sell Arenas like on their own sure but
most of them like the like the baby
little baby uh the Migos
um a lotto like they all have to pair up
and make an event in order to sell it
out like there's no one Headliners like
there's like Drake Jay-Z Kanye they can
do it outside in like even you know J
Cole outside that like it's like they
have to get together like uh Blue Collar
Comedy Tour to sell tickets to sell
Arenas out they have to all band
together so if you go you know like oh
Miko's [ __ ] the baby little baby like
Migos like you can't do it just on your
shirt most of them all suck at
performing live dude is it because
they're really bad performing lines
maybe other bands don't want to perform
with him just yet is that what's going
on uh I don't maybe yeah
so what happens is you're [ __ ] don't
be associated with it yeah now you're
you might be killing it no you can't be
with him yeah yeah I didn't think of
that yeah that's what I think happened I
just
hold on a second yeah this pissed me off
this was this final statement that we
put out that was like an hour long but I
just wanted to show a couple of Snippets
from it to get a taste I want the world
to know in my final statement that if
you're a supporter of mine and I know
most of you are please explain the truth
in a respectful manner telling these
hate-filled people that they're wrong
and calling them names these people are
not happy people because happy people
don't act that way tell them the truth
show them that the content is out of
context show them the long format
content say all the ways I've helped you
and I really believe by being a
genuinely professional logical positive
person you guys can change public
Consciousness for me and time is a
beautiful thing it's amazing how things
change with time and in the meantime I'm
going to enjoy my fantastic life which
I've managed to build with all of the
tenacity and mental strength that I try
and teach my fans you know how to reach
me and I'll finish with a quote from my
late father my unmatched perspicacity
coupled with sheer fatigability makes me
a feared opponent in any realm of human
endeavor he's a bad [ __ ] man I
like this bad [ __ ] fight too
[ __ ] I like him man me too
good message yeah
my unmatched as smart as [ __ ] using
those words coupled with sheer
indefatigability
makes me a feared opponent
in any realm of human endeavor his dad
was like a master chess player I guess
oh that makes sense it'd be Wicked smart
well um
doesn't he have his own where can people
find him his website probably yeah his
his school's still going and it's
interesting because the way that he's
been framed every time I hear somebody
who's answer him they go he's really big
with teenagers as if this isn't a mature
adult like you know Jake Paul was big
with teenagers this guy is Big with
anybody who has a brain to me yeah to me
this guy's big with everybody it took
all this yeah this guy's big with males
this guy's big with males it's just not
that's a huge sin now teenagers might be
into it because there's no outlet for
this right but yeah who are you to
silence him because teenagers find him
motivational or whatever it's dangerous
yeah because he's corrupting the Youth
of Athens they killed Socrates because
he was corrupting the Youth of Athens
it's the same idea I'm not comparing him
no no no no no but it is yeah to the
left who canceled him who who would you
want these young guys to look up to give
me give me replace him well first of all
no no no no no no they don't want them
to they don't want to look up you don't
want young men to look up to anybody
they don't the left doesn't speak for
young men the left wants to turn young
men into young women yeah yes they don't
have a positive vision for masculinity
they know what they don't like
communities
it's masculinity is equated with
patriarchy tyranny oppression rape War
murder that's how they look at
masculinity they never ever highlight
masculinity as well you know what they
highlight you know what they think of as
positive masculinity lack of masculinity
right masculinity that emulates
femininity feminine men
castrated neutered men who they they
take all the aggression out of boys
contact Sports and MB how's that going
for them well I mean it's it's not going
it's not nature it's not but also how's
it going for it right
yeah name one thing they've done that
helped move the ball forward nothing
nothing yeah why why Silicon Valley you
know who who created that [ __ ] yeah
and then the other thing I was going to
say is it's also been painted as a
multi-level marketing scheme his
university because one of the ways in
which you can get money is to use his
Clips to like make your own YouTube
channel he's like make your own YouTube
channel uses clips and
um you can make money from that but
that's one of like 18 different ways
it's not about him my thing is that you
you have these huge tech companies
censoring outright literally erasing
somebody yeah and I think that's wrong
right what part of the argument was he's
a scam artist but I go no he's not
that's a legitimate way to make money
he's like hey I'm giving you all this
raw material go do something creative
yeah
which is what's her name just galbas no
no
so goop that was selling Jade eggs to
put in your [ __ ] okay or they sell a
lot of products is that being a scam
artist should she not be allowed to sell
that women want to buy it yeah so wait
hold on how about different supplements
right should we allow all no supplements
until we have all the science there are
a lot of supplements out there that
there are a lot of makeup
skin creams that are supposed to make
you look younger do they really work I
don't think so I agree so what are we
doing here yeah if part of the argument
is scam Artistry
they're basically making it out to be a
pyramid scheme which is he got too big
yeah too big too big of a fallen he's
going against the grain so they shut
them down yeah he's also I'm sorry he's
also a man of color I mean if you guys
are not Prejudice that is black but also
it's like people should be scared man we
need to come up with other ways to
create Revenue 100 dude yeah you're out
of your mind you don't think this
episode gets demonetized guarantee
Andrew mate
yeah we can take out the drug talk no no
don't get me started yeah
let's feel so hard what we got here is a
little update on
the story from last week Ohio woman uh
whose dad fatally shot
ex-boyfriends his victim changed after
split the Ohio woman whose ex-boyfriend
has gone down by her dad told cops the
Fatal victim was verbally abusive and
changed after they broke up um he died
from gunshot wound we know that
and they had done acid together I guess
that's why the girl and the boyfriend
brought this up yeah
um
according to the woman she and rail
would take acid while they were dating
but she said she did not know if he was
still using illicit drugs around the
time of his death because she had not
been in contact with him Allison also
recounted the events that immediately
preceded the Bloodshed
um
she said that when she saw the glass in
the front door break and the door frame
give way
she freaked out and ran and hid I didn't
even see when Michael duckrow Mitchell
duckrow shot or anything I just heard it
the daughter recalled I literally hid
most of the time I screamed a bunch and
then I really started freaking out the
night before the shooting rail had left
a voicemail for Allison which was
released this month by the man's sister
who has been leading a campaign to
Manning Justice for her brother Hi
Elliot it's James rails says Softly on
the recording I just wanted to reach out
to you because I just wanted to see how
you're doing yeah and maybe hear from
you and it comes around and tries to
break in though so it wasn't he
threatened to kill her or no
it just cheat in my opinion if you're
trying to break in hold on
uh
if you're trying to break into
somebody's house like that and the guy
goes I have a gun and you're St and you
still break in the house yeah she was oh
she goes Dad is he trying to kill me
Allison could be hurt saying the 911
silver
yeah it shows the man standing oh okay
sorry
and part of this is I wouldn't recommend
doing acid for teenagers
when we talk about this stuff yeah let
your brain form but uh you know it's
just so stupid and then Mom says it too
of the daughter wait what about I can't
imagine what I can go back up and go
back up to the beginning yeah where's
the biker getting involved
that's a mouse
Paul mogalevsky the first degree murder
bogalesky is currently being held in the
Pinellas County Jail with no bond
discharge stems from the April 27 2022
murder of Dominic Pastor Noster
and that murder occurred at his
residence of 104 dunbridge Drive in Palm
Harbor
all right
let's go down a little bit more yeah
it was like biker gangs killing
so Mike Mitchell Dell Crow
against indicting okay
stand your ground law yeah
uh I think they saw this and it looks
like yeah shouldn't do me a favor go
that one that says the more in shootings
is Colorado teen shot and killed while
filming a tick tock dance
and play that for the view I don't want
to see this
I don't see this we saw that other key
get shot oh teen girl she's fatally shot
in the head well oh
[Music]
let me scroll down here hold on just
two teen girls have been arrested ow
when the suspects right just I don't
know uh when asked if shooting could
have been acting the girl replied it
could be an accident one of the suspects
had access to the gun through her
boyfriend who owned it legally affidavit
affidavit allegedly she then allegedly
showed it to those two girls while
making their videos The Tick Tock
recorded moments before the shooting
showed the victim death while in person
in the background is filling with
something on the bed yeah it sounds like
oh yeah it sounds like an accent
um two miners could face maximum six
years damn dude the Freshman I got if
you take a life you'd have to pay for it
dude
lock those guys not if it's an accident
yeah I agree that's terrible
anybody else get Sean kilchin what else
you got Jesus Christ that's terrible
wanna do this one
yes
video shows NYC cop punching woman in
the face to the ground
all right
that's the guy looks like it
do we not get the video see let's wait
for it to load your shocking video shows
an NYPD cop punching chin scroll Point
too fast
look look this video is playing but it's
not playing the big players how to do
that oh I see you yeah I see what you
did there yeah
I'll rewind it Jen you already punch you
in the face rewind it
oh oh well she hit him right yep she hit
him and then
[Applause]
she's a young kid in this giant black
dude socks her in the [ __ ] problem
yeah yeah it's a problem listen as a cop
he should have some control you could
have killed her well he's I'd assume
he's [ __ ] yeah yes what and why so
what'd she do
so they were there uh like protesting
the arrest of a murder suspect I guess
uh the NYPD said they moved to arrest
demand in connection with the an
attempted murder on Tuesday
um
outside the 32nd Precinct
uh you know I I don't know so they're
all yeah they're all outside of uh cop
Precinct I do think that this woman you
gotta let's not punch a cop let's not
come at a cop well she pushed the cup
right and then she hit him I think right
well she put she pushed him go back and
let me see what she does again I don't
I'm not hitting again but here's my
thing so you push the cup bro you're
probably 270 pounds yeah you're gonna
punch a teenager in the face I agree
that's that's your that's unequal very
dangerous he that was way 100 don't
touch a [ __ ] cop just hell don't push
him but that's way too excessive yeah
that's [ __ ] nuts he rocked her you
can't do that don't be that afraid of
her okay
she's 16. she hits you all right also
you didn't scratch when she pushed you
didn't budge
all she did was
it
she hits her head on the side I got a
big problem in that she could have died
yeah it's not good
[Applause]
cops right now all time hot you know
they're dealing with allotments who
knows he he might have came listen I'm
not saying he should he shouldn't have
punched her at all he should you know
sustained her and held her down or
pushed her down yeah but she might have
came from a a previous crime you know is
there a chance he pushed her no that's a
punch
but also you don't fall down have you
ever had the instinct to
even touch a police officer never like I
wouldn't even cross no no well even even
me like I'd I don't get shot well
there's a romance to the idea of being
like I'm gonna get arrested for
disorderly conducted
yeah punching yeah well either way uh
that's uh that's a real punch man oh and
she hits her head up she could have
killed her
that was bad there's no need for it no
no no I'm not I'm not
well folks theoc is back at it again
posting a dancing clip I wish it was
ugly this one she drives me nuts she's
obviously other [ __ ] she's batshit
crazy she's so hot
what is she doing she's dancing in
support of our uh Finnish prime minister
friend who oh by the way somebody
commented on last week's tfat Camp
episode with some interesting context a
finished person was saying look you see
this clip and it's like oh my God she's
just trying to have fun why do they he's
like there's way more to it dude she was
like days that she said she would be in
office she was drinking like all night
because she was drunk it was like eight
things he listed oh it's like this girl
has a problem and also she made a big
deal about the drug test she was like no
no she took it like a week later they
were like you can take it right now you
have shoes on coke yeah right she's like
oh no I'll take it next week
so is she she's like trouble or she's
back to work well well that's why the
society is like hey hey [ __ ] you should
be [ __ ] doing raging parties no
if you want to elect a hot 37 or 36 year
old lady
head of your [ __ ] country you're
gonna have to it's gonna come well
that's like Bill Clinton it's like you
know what you signed up for yeah dick
sucked in the Oval Office get a copy
yeah and that guy was out of control
right like yeah but you voted him in
he's had all these allegations before
and then Linda Tripp just came finally
came out and was like did another
interview she runs a Christmas shop in
like [ __ ] Maine or something like
that now she came out she's like oh
there's thousands of women like there's
a rotating door like yeah he's a Savage
the idea that it was just and then she
was like but even that like he's a
terrible human being nobody's worse than
Hillary Clinton like Hillary knew all
these women and she was just whatever
about it but if they said anything she
would ruin their lives and she says
she's Pro like female movement she goes
there can be a more options you know who
voted against her women white women her
age were like this [ __ ] is a frog a
[ __ ] oh man it's a terrible human being
well well uh I think if Clinton ran
today he might win I think he could beat
[ __ ] I mean he can't but yeah no but
he would he would be a guy if you said
you're allowed to run against Trump I I
he's so Obama would beat him
Obama would beat him yeah I think so
yeah I think Obama beat Trump I do too
but they have nothing who's gonna beat
him Newsome no
Buddha Gage and [ __ ] Kamal hairs you
guys are [ __ ] no yeah yeah it's not
happening oh man but yeah it's funny
because she flattens it oh she flattens
it down to like
you know women Empower her dance I'm all
for it but it's like it's not about that
it's not about somebody getting in
trouble for dancing she was doing drugs
all weekend she was on a bender
and you know what I like her more right
right now I don't want to run in my
country it's an example of like almost
like the silicone thing where it's like
you're reducing it down to like she's a
woman she's great it's like what about
all the other things though if that's a
guy out partying all the time like the
mayor of [ __ ] uh New York seen him
Adams yeah just he's with French Montana
oh he is oh dude he's smoking I didn't
know that oh he's wild and they're like
hey crime suffer been higher he's like
chill chill you give me a cigar right
yeah because you don't care until it
interferes with your job yeah I know I
know a lot I know some guys who were on
the force with him yeah and he was uh
never really getting involved and he had
his eyes on this prize for a long time
oh he never really made a lot of arrests
well he's not doing anything cramps
through the roof he's just partying and
[ __ ] wow going to like fancy dinners
people are so frustrated with him
is that itching one more yeah yeah I
guess if it's good yeah oh no yeah he
broke over there because she turned 20.
and he girl over 25 gives him more
they're all so hot like they're like
every one of them is just like even
better now that they're 25 and they're
gonna get better when they're 35. every
23 year old girl is like here we go baby
so strange what is this the other guy
would call him come on Monroe on her
25th birthday hey hey happy birthday
yokie sir
hey happy birthday you old geezer
[Music]
[ __ ] sell me
Miley Cyrus walking away
it says really wants his girlfriend's
brain finishes development
and kisses her hand waves Goodbye Miley
Cyrus yeah it is oh my God she's so
talented her how dude dude as soon as
something's wrong with that yeah 25 is
all I hate it God he's disciplined and
look at his body like he doesn't give a
[ __ ] no savage
and what do you guys think about it like
because people really judge him and I've
heard so many women be like there's
something wrong with him like do you
think that's if you're a billionaire
with access to any girl you want like do
you just Oh you mean you mean 23 year
old women are attractive to older men
it's like as old as time this just
didn't yeah so can you believe him if
that's not a full woman or anything
that's not a full grown woman yeah I
mean yes look at that child this is
gorgeous yeah okay yeah and she's not
having the time of her life in any other
time in history she'd have four kids by
now yeah and she'll have the time of her
life on Yachts [ __ ] going to award
shows after you one for the [ __ ]
Reverend and [ __ ] like what are we
talking about the top of the mountain
yeah yeah
at the time she was 19 but still good
time for him
and her do you think they make him they
make or he makes them sign a contract
I'm sure oh he's got it dude he's
looking around at what happened and he's
like they they tried to come for him
yeah and he that's why he doesn't do you
know he doesn't do interviews like the
only podcast he's ever done was Mark
Mann and it was four it was four Once
the time in Hollywood Mark Maron and
Brad Pitt Brad Pitt some Marc Maron fan
yeah so Brad talked Leonardo into it and
Leonardo kicks off he's like listen I
don't do interviews I'll do podcasts
that's crazy he's also surrounded by
like a very tight-knit group of guys
he's had with them for a long time yeah
Toby Maguire
at least played the infamous Hollywood
with a poker game in millions and
millions at all Jonah Hill too they're
close yep I wonder if the girls have to
sign like when you're saying sign stuff
I wonder if the girls have to sign
something saying like if we break up you
can't say anything about me yeah
you ever heard a bad thing about
Leonardo DiCaprio ever in your life
never they can't they get sued to the
[ __ ] roof ndas are [ __ ] air tight
Daddy yeah airtight yeah so with
Leonardo DiCaprio's team it's a
nightmare
smart already we might get a season just
assistant this is the guy who grew up in
Hollywood watching people fall watching
what really goes on when you're famous
the Heat Big the very famous people got
to him when he was young like Jack Nick
yeah he uses black building like Jack
Gibson they they educated him 100 they
realize how you move that's what you do
you get a house behind nobody's your
friend you need a house behind one oh
okay you meet a young lady a few of them
right and you go back and forth okay but
but but those guys said people the Press
is never your friend
interviews you never see him doing
anything he's a Savage very rare
and I'll tell you where you don't have
to sign an NDA at Appleton Wisconsin
Appleton is next week Thursday through
Saturday uh September 8th through the
10th is Appleton Wisconsin then I'm at
one of my favorite clubs ever Ontario
Improv that's one of the first firing
kids we did yes it is about seven eight
years ago my man more than that bubble
yeah I know isn't it nuts yeah Ontario
Improv September 15th through 17th then
I end September in Boston laugh Boston
almost sold out September 29th through
October 1st awesome October I'm in San
Jose and Salt Lake City get your tickets
now but
um Appleton Ontario Boston September
gets tickets at thickboy.com tonight's
show at the Improv is sold out already
shopping friends sold out it's Chris
D'Elia uh Theo Von Rappaport and David
Spade oh it's a nice lineup isn't that
fun I could not look more Mexican though
I look pure Mexican there yep you really
do in a good way uh Raleigh North
Carolina good night September 8th and
9th and 10th San Jose California The
Improv September 15 16 17. Spokane
Washington Spokane Comedy Club September
22 23 24. that's all in September I'm in
Raleigh San Jose Spokane then Bridgeport
Connecticut Stress Factory October 13 14
15. Tacoma Washington Tacoma Comedy Club
September 29th you gotta switch you got
to switch Tacoma in front of Bridgeport
right because Tacoma is September 29th
holy [ __ ] and bridgeport's October hello
hi hello hello
thank you that's really weird what can
you do all right this is the fine kid
we're out